Darrell is with us in New York hi
Darrell how are you hey hi how you doing
Dave better than I deserve man your
question for dr. D and me yes I'm a new
listener of viewers and I'm a big fan I
wish like I started you know years ago
but my question is I'm 35 and I have an
outrageous student loan of one hundred
and sixty three thousand dollars five
hundred out one hundred fifty thousand
dollars and seventy seven dollars and I
just don't know what to do like I just
feel I feel stuck I have no other no
other bills I mean no other loans no
card no nothing no credit cards okay the
[Applause]
woody wood should agree in graduated
with a degree in exercise science I'm a
personal trainer okay so what's your
household income make about twenty nine
thousand one hundred and twelve dollars
okay what are we gonna do get your
income up way up since you're spending
hundred sixty-three thousand to get this
degree we need to earn more with it yeah
and I just don't know what what else to
do like ah I just started the this step
one and I'm almost to $1,000 but I just
feel like maybe every time I get paid I
have to pay something yeah well you live
in New York and you make twenty nine
thousand you're starving to death
yeah plus or minus plus or minus one
hundred and sixty-three thousand in
student loans right I mean if you know
if you had no loans you've got no picnic
here so we got to do something with your
career man so what do people with
exercise science do that makes a lot
more money than what you're doing
honestly a lot of people either are
exercise physiologist where they work in
the clinical setting I wanted to do more
personal training so I guess I have my
own brand out trying to get started you
know to get some more revenue in mm-hm
and that's just it does is the best one
I can think of so what does someone am I
thought of someone in a clinical
situation what kind of money do they
make I'm really honestly I'm not sure
I would guess 50 mm-hmm if that okay
well I do know from 29,000 a year that
you're not working you're not staying
busy mmm okay as a trainer you're not
working a tour you're exhausted every
day not even close
you could you could take on a whole lot
more clients agreed agree well right now
it's the I'm sorry I'm from New York I'm
in West Virginia that's where I went to
school and now works from twelve to nine
everyday twelve noon to 9:00 at night
yeah what do you charge them per hour
six bucks must be the cheapest make
about I make about fourteen hmm okay
well here's the thing there's two sides
to the equation the income side and the
outgo side and I'm not sure how I'm
going to have all the answers for you
today
on the income side but I do know you
have to fix that because that's where
that's where your problem is
mathematical okay okay which means we
have to reset how we're thinking about
your career because I truly want you to
make a hundred and twenty nine thousand
and you're going to have to have a
different model than you've gotten now
to do that I don't know whether it's day
job at the clinic at the clinic and 450
thousand plus 29 thousand dollars worth
of training and you do a lot better
charging by the hour on your training
and you become self-employed on your
training instead of working for somebody
else at 14 bucks because you gets laid
there and you know and again don't don't
take this as a put-down I'm just trying
to help you with the math I'm not saying
you're a bad guy I'm not saying you're
lazy I'm not saying you Dom or you did
something wrong we've just got a we have
to do something to get your income up
because you have an income crisis and
thus the student loans look hopeless
because I don't know you know if you pay
$10 a year on them you're not going to
make it you know so we've got to do
something to considerably change your
whole paradigm on that let me give you a
copy of ken Coleman's book the proximity
principle dive in on his website the Ken
Coleman show or Ken Coleman calm and
start to learn some
his career direction that he gives folks
and help with that because that's where
the math problem is for you man I'm
honored to have you as a new listener
you call me anytime I'll help you any
way I can but that's what I'm seeing
where you are today you've gonna have to
change that may take you a little time
but but you know you don't wanna be
sitting where you're sitting ten years
from now you will not have made much
progress
John you spent all this time in higher
ed I know what that call does inside my
stomach what does it do inside yours
when a guy spends that kind of money
together a degree to make that kind of
money and just breaks my heart it's just
a breakdown of it's a breakdown on the
fall from start to finish I mean I'm
talking quieter now I hate those calls
I hate those hearts I've had those
conversations for years it just breaks
my heart
it's the I people get a picture in their
head of what they're they you know get
quote-unquote passionate about a thing
and that overrides their ability to
think what's this job gonna look like
what's the day-to-day grind of this job
gonna look like what's the realities of
what this job is gonna pay versus what
I'm spending to get the degree what am i
what a parts of my soul am i putting on
the line that I'm gonna have to pay back
for a long time all right and yeah it
just breaks my heart
yeah because you get you get a situation
now or I think I think college and
universities as a was a good thing and
right now with this current economic
situation he's worse off right you can
go make $14 an hour flipping burgers
anywhere yeah he is worse off for having
been through this experience financially
and so if he will use some of the things
that he learned and start making
connections that Ken talks about I'm
glad you found you I'm glad he's making
the phone call but man that just gets me
fired up inside yeah hurts why in the
lesson for our listeners was this get
get Anthony's book for your teenager on
man debt-free degree and be thinking
about a couple things
obviously you don't go into debt for the
degree not picking on him he's just he's
just what everybody doesn't marry me you
know that's right just but it's it's
that sure when a guy like that calls the
show for the rest of you listening
that's use that's that's a message to
you when you got a fourteen-year-old
says don't well do that and so I'm gonna
get it
regardless of that that is gonna give me
a return on investment
meaning I'm gonna get a degree that is a
marketable job that is gonna pay me
considerably more because I got the
degree than I would have made without
the degree and it's gonna it's gonna put
me in contact with experiences and with
mentors and with job prospects that I
wouldn't have been able to have had I
not had that route the other thing he
mentioned is he's 35 and I saw I've seen
this a lot throughout my higher ed
career which is someone gets to be 26 27
28 and they don't like their trajectory
and so they get a they kind of invent
this future for themselves and they they
decide that this is the only way through
it and they take on an extraordinary
amount of loans and they get the dead
set on one thing and they get out and
they're now they're 35 and they own this
kind of money well I tell you where it
happens to most is were you thinking
with your heart and they're there that
there's sweet people kind people
compassionate people and they want to
help in some area and they don't stop
and do the math with it so another
example of that is I'm gonna be a social
worker hmm so I spend $250,000 my
undergrad and my Masters in Social Work
in order to get licensed to make 38,000
working for the state now that's dumber
than a rock that's right but that's your
heart being huge and overriding your
brain your brain and wanting to help and
you're not making good choices in and
there's nobody in your life that says no
don't do that that's stupid and so moms
and dads you got a if you got a kid
that's on that track you know we'll just
live your passion horse crowd you know
no you don't wanna live your passion
live your dream you turn your dream into
a nightmare when you do it wrong and so
yeah you can live your passion but you
need to do it in a way that's wise
responsible in a way that's intelligent
we're the 30 year old version of you
doesn't hate the 18 year old version of
you I had a great counseling professor
that said she said you cannot honorably
and with dignity take care of clients if
you're worried about paying your bills
you can't bring your full self to that
Wow that's harsh she was right it was
right dr. John Delon he joins me this
hour this is the Dave Ramsey show